hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast come on
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
fun if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
saturday afternoon down here
aunt tooty's basement holiday season in
bloom she's got the tree up it smells
like cookies
my co-host yeah coming at you from right
next to me my good pal
my best pal in the world he cooks the
books he keeps us honest
give it up for kippy kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang what's up everybody
happy to be
here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
uh
and then how we pay the bills baby
patreon.com
uh you can get bonus episodes every week
and get multiple episodes every week
we're doing a live stream with the
with the uh with the fans uh you can
sign up for all that
it's a good time also t-shirts at
podcastmerge.com
uh gang do us a favor real quick let's
tip our hat to our producer
extraordinaire
magic man mr t-bone toby mcmullen
everybody
hey we love you pal just in time for the
holidays gang
we have an incredibly special guest here
with us today we are so excited to have
him
you guys requested him you wanted him so
bad we finally got him here
he is a very funny stand-up comedian
actor and podcaster
as an actor you've seen him in girls or
roommates as a comedian you've seen him
on just for laughs all access
gotham comedy live jeff ross rose battle
conan
in his own comedy central half hour and
he is of course the host
of the sit down with mike razine but the
big question in his mind today is he
garbage
well he [ __ ] stiffed us twice
but we got him here ladies and gentlemen
give me a big round of applause for the
one
the only micro scene yeah my game
you're right i can't tell if he loves me
or hates me what do you mean you see
strong silent type and the stash is even
more intimidating
when you took your mask off you were
like a gun fighter with that thing
i like it thanks you got to stop
thinking about if people like you
well welcome to foleyville that's all
he's worried about right there's only a
few and you're one of them
that like you know that really that
really sticking your brain you know
everybody has those couples i have
gotten that
i do get that a lot yeah you're an
intimidating guy yeah i don't understand
i got one ball what do you want from me
what the [ __ ] don't ruin it for me come
on
my penis never gets hard yeah
that's your super powers it's all backed
up yeah
yeah you're just a quiet you're quieter
you know what i mean you're not like
most comics come into a green room and
are like look at you know begging for
attention or you just come in and you're
like you're scoping out the scene you
played in the back
i'm like a sniper yeah i think you got a
lot of people worried
for scenes lying in the bushes standing
by the door yeah
keep you on their toes well i like to
make sure i want to make sure if i open
my mouth some you know i got some
funnies i want to have a good batting
average
there you go that's good that's very old
school so i can't think of anything
funny to say i just
shut that's why he's quiet most of the
time come on
let me ask you this do you i know a
little bit about you yeah i'm not 100
sure
i i have a general idea uh i don't think
you're garbage
do you think you're garbage um i don't
know probably i probably was at a
certain point in my life and i think
as i'm getting older i've tried not to
be i think i kind of missed out on a
whole
there's a big like a big there's a part
of your life where you learn like you
know morality
and integrity yeah and i think i learned
that a little later in life
why um i don't know because i feel like
i i moved i moved to the city to do
comedy very young i moved here when i
was like 20.
from jersey right new jersey yeah so i
had like two years of
i had two years of college under my belt
dropped out of college i so i went to
college
montclair state okay same one that i
think carmela soprano dropped out sure
yeah yeah new jersey state school
yeah yeah in the hallways yeah
don't come when she's threatening
someone to get a
recommendation yeah you're gonna give my
kid a translation to montclair state
yeah that's an impression that i think i
can do but i i don't ever have
i don't know carmella yeah i feel like i
can only do tony
the varanzano bridge tony yeah there's
times where i think uh
that gandolfini gave the best
performance on that show sometimes i
think uncle june
then every once in a while i'll catch a
scene with her and you'll just be like
god damn
she [ __ ] killed she was very good
she's very she's very understated too
you know when they get a divorce and she
they have that big fight and she's
screaming i'm losing my mind
oh i get choked up every time yeah
because you could have played that
character
cartoony you know yeah yeah yeah but she
was very
understated but you got the yeah you
wonder so you picked up on the vibes
for sure our vibes yeah it's good stuff
tell us the back story then since we're
going down this way we're in jail yeah
all right so i was like
so i went to college for two years in
jersey i was working at a um
a marketing uh company a window and
siding marketing body i did the same
thing you did
were you powered who were you working
for uh home fix okay one of the
questions i've asked is
have you ever sold anything door-to-door
over the phone oh yeah you go sign them
up try to sign them up for estimates and
then sit them down and do the hard close
so wait you're going to the house you go
in the living room and close
no you don't close you don't you send a
closer in you're an appointment set or
you're a canvas or you go to hey listen
i noticed your [ __ ] gutters hanging
off how about i get a you know what's
going to take people
with some big dick to lock it down some
real stuff they send like
they sent a real scumbag yeah who comes
in he's got like you're just like the
junior scumbag
exactly kid you're not ready for this
dude go wait in the car they would
always be like this isn't going to be a
high pressure thing i'm like no not at
all you know we got the best prices and
then something
some little scumbag comes in and goes
yeah it's gonna be uh 75 grand for the
new roof
jimmy valvoline putting the screws to
your wife it's always can you sign today
they want to know if both decision
makers are going to be there and can you
sign today
decision making i don't want to say any
i don't want to trash any
because i just set the appointments for
the sales guys
but i know that there were some
companies that would do a thing where
they go hey i'm the director of
marketing for this company
what we want to do is we want to have
your house be a model home we're going
to we're going to give you a 30
40 discount um to have your home we're
going to hand out flyers we're going to
you know blah blah blah
and uh they would think they're getting
a discount but they're actually getting
bamboo so theoretically not that you did
but you could pretend you were anybody
on the other end of that phone
technically what do you mean he was
going door-to-door door-to-door
yeah we're looking for a property in
this neighborhood to make you know set
up to be the example
like i'm just like a little i'm just a
college kid yeah
you got a clipboard a couple of flyers
yeah and they go all right i just want
an estimate
yeah it's good for a whole year free
estimate good for you and then they they
show up they send some guy to you have
some scum
[ __ ] [ __ ] who works for like three
different companies
yeah he's selling cars he's selling
siding that dude's selling everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah and but it was it
was a fun it was a nice little taste
but it was a nice little introduction to
because i remember one time
like there was a there was this guy nick
who was like the canvassing manager
because he he did sales i was the
canvassing manager yeah you were yeah
yeah yeah yeah i had a degree not
bragging i'm not right i used to drive i
used to drive
a minivan around with a bunch of
delinquents damn dude you
and i remember my scumbag family being
like so proud of me oh
oh you're making so much money selling
those windows
and like i'm just i'm just knocking
making like 30 bucks mikey how many
people are you ready
today i'll tell you what when i think
back on it what i feel really bad about
is that sometimes you would go to a
neighborhood that was like
um a suburb that was mostly like people
of color
okay like black people and they would
always they would
really they would sign up for the free
estimate you know what i mean
black people and also like indian people
yeah
would want the free estimate they
wouldn't buy anything and then the sales
guys would complain and be like the
sales guys don't send me to someone
yeah the sales guys would get very
opinionated on the names
uh yeah but if you if you ever went to
like a like a
like i think maybe white like white
people are we maybe we do have a little
evil
gene in us or something because you go
to these
like black suburbs there's like you know
affluent
black people they trust you you know
right and you but so yeah and they sign
up and they don't always
sometimes they buy sometimes they don't
i think suburban white people are the
more ones that say yes to it though
like people have colored me like get the
[ __ ] out suburban white people no
suburban white people are like
no i think suburban white people like
get out of my apartment do you have a
permit
i'm gonna call the cops you know they
know the [ __ ]
chief of police and their shitty town
yeah you know
do you have permits for this permits for
this
oh yeah yeah ran out by the cops for
sure yeah you got to call all the
canvassers and be like hey i'll meet you
at the front entrance and we got to get
back
yeah because [ __ ] i didn't because
you're supposed to get a canvassing
permit but
they don't give them out ever no and
you're in a new town every night so it's
easier to just go
get the cops called on you maybe they
bring you down to the station
to rough you up a bit yeah yeah yeah how
long did you do this
uh in college so like my first two years
of end of high school first two years of
college
now when you say this was your first run
and as far as like morality
how was it growing up was it you never
saw anything like that
uh what'd your parents do if you don't
mind me well my so my dad uh
works i guess he does like commercial
lending at a bank
white collar guy smart guy um yeah i
guess yeah okay
seems like he's got some opinions on his
dad
um but i do remember they have a weird
like morality thing they do have this
weird thing
they're very into morals and i remember
when when bill clinton got a blow job it
was like they were really upset
really they're really really upset that
he'd like disgrace this country
yeah your parents are not like me yeah
but they don't have a problem with trump
you know paying off porn stars or
anything
so okay i don't know it's very weird
yeah i don't know
how many brothers and sisters you have
growing up i have three younger
siblings so i have two younger brothers
and a younger sister
how much further uh we're all two years
apart oh really yeah so you were big
brother mike
yeah and what'd your mom do she uh
she stayed home and then when i when i
was in high school she went back and she
uh worked as a sub and now she's she's
still a sub
she sub at your high school no but she
subbed at like uh
she subbed it like so my brother is
special needs he has autism okay
so she subbed at his school nice um yeah
so she so
so the school had two wings and one was
like uh
kids with disabilities okay and the
other was called b-wing it was like all
behavioral kids
from like the inner cities that got
kicked out of their high schools and got
sent over there so she would sub at that
school too
and i remember like the first day she
yeah she came home she was like uh
like a like a cop you know like a cop
put her back yeah put her gun on the
counter yeah yeah yeah and just like had
to go to therapy
a thousand mile stare but then she ended
up i guess liking it because she still
works there so i guess she ended up kind
of like winning some of those kids over
and
learning how to deal with them and you
know it's like every movie yeah
you know you taught him how to she was
like teach him how to dance yeah she
taught him
shakespeare but shakespeare was kind of
like jay-z would think about it they won
a national competition
yeah yeah yeah doing a movie about it
with sandy ball she coached their step
team or something
but she kind of did that yeah did she
stay did she not work growing up to take
care of your brother or was it more
initially yeah well when we were younger
yeah she didn't work
and then when i was in high school my
sister was in middle school she went
back to work she just likes to work
i got you so i'm seeing that you know
that your dad was making enough cash to
support everybody
so it must have been pretty nice i guess
initially he was yeah single family home
uh in the beginning yeah so she's a
stay-at-home mom so that was cool
she was like a room mother you know she
got really into
yeah she was like a great mom really
into halloween and stuff
oh that's nice you know yeah wait and
you say in the beginning
when was there a turn and what happened
when i was in high school she went back
to work
i don't know why i think she just wanted
to work as the kids were but she started
still in the same house
okay yeah he made it sound like
something happened and they were like in
one regional apartment somewhere oh no
okay no fair enough yeah she was good at
hiding
her mental illness too i think this
guy's this guy's like a big italian
onion over here
you think it's over yeah you think
you're crying
it gives you the staring yeah no i don't
know
she told me one time she was like you
know one time you'd go to your
grandparents house because i wanted to
drive the tree that caught the car into
a tree
i do i think about that all the time
it's like well you did a good job of
not doing that but the cupcakes were on
point i'll tell you that
yeah yeah yeah wait when was this i
don't know probably like when i was
in like middle school i guess now did
you were you aware this at the time
when it happened did you find out about
it no okay but we we
i think we went through different phases
with my brother just because him being
special needs okay you know you go
through like the phase where
you know he's two and he's going to
therapy he just starts therapy and it's
like tough
you know and then he gets and then he
gets older and then he's a teenager
every couple of years every couple of
years different periods that you're
running they're like [ __ ] we gotta you
know
figure this out yeah so that was wearing
on her um
yeah probably yeah and your pop
um i get hit i know he just worked a lot
okay he just worked a lot and made money
off the iraq war
and there's a lot on the street by real
estate you know what i mean
so you do come from a little bit of
money there's a little bit of money
there
um i guess i mean yeah we're not like i
guess we're pretty middle class
i wouldn't say like oh my family was
poor or anything all right
but uh did you get a car when you were
in high school i paid for it myself i
paid at 96 yeah but maybe he could have
worked the old man to get one
probably yeah because they got my i
think they got my brother one or he got
my grim
he got my great special needs subaru
yeah my the special needs
he's not killing it they got him a uh
um no but i remember my mom like
throughout
me being a teenager making it a big deal
like oh yeah you want to like
you want to get your own you want to pay
for your own car yeah you don't want to
be
the kind of person whose parents buy you
a car so they can put that stuff into
you so that's where we're going
so yeah coming from a little bit of
class uh good work yeah i guess
yeah oh definitely good workout that's
the vibe i get and what was the car
it was a 96 saturn over the saturn yeah
the two-door
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no four-door
it was nice it was it was uh 2003.
still pretty i remember pa i paid for it
i paid cash for the car with my own
money because i was working at a
grocery store when i was in school oh
groceries i worked so tough too what's
that
i worked at a grocery store too that is
tough yeah it's either high school kids
or
[ __ ] fellows or career yeah career
workers
yeah but uh i think grocery store
cashier was the worst job i've ever had
to this day yeah that's tough it's
[ __ ] tough it's every six minutes
you're dealing with just someone else
and then like
i remember the one time this guy was
arguing over like the price of [ __ ]
rice-a-roni was coming up yeah yeah yeah
15 cents more or something like that and
i'm like there was it was like
thanksgiving there's a line of [ __ ]
500 people you're in the weeds you've
been working for nine hours
yeah uh and he's and i remember he it
was like 25 cents off
yeah and i just reached in my pocket and
i took a quarter
yeah i just said here man i got it yeah
yeah yeah and that was not the answer he
was looking for dude every
every manager district manager [ __ ]
regional manager
i had [ __ ] but i was in a union so
they couldn't fire me
so
yeah that's the top of the line it
doesn't get better in a suburban grocery
store than wegmans
for sure who'd you know they got you in
there i think i just
i just like wanted to when i cause they
opened when i was like 14
when i was in eighth grade that's a real
thursday night and i was like
i'm a work kid someday i want to work
here yeah
ride buying your bikes yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're always like
stupid but one day because because i
liked food i was like so impressed with
that
fantastic it's a great 14 thousand you
could drive a car down those aisles too
though yeah yeah yeah
so i started off doing like bagging and
then and then they put me on registered
registered registers sucked i mean do
you remember what the code for bananas
is
four four zero one one ah man everybody
remembers that forever
yeah wait is it four zero one one for
you two yeah it says i mean it's most of
the country is four zero zero four zero
there's a universal
code for bananas how about scallions oh
[ __ ] i want to say four zero eight eight
i think it's four zero six eight
okay yes i think you're right four zero
eight eight i think it's red vine
tomatoes
if i or four four six four six six four
that's
right yeah
you got a couple of cashiers over what's
uh what's three zero zero one one
your weight [ __ ] dorks
[ __ ] lob one up like that doing codes
so that's what dude
they're [ __ ] in
no it's weird because my family is like
middle and i'm surprised that i'm like
kind of a dirt bag
because my i could have been i could
have done more with my life
you know what you're doing all right no
don't sell yourself short
no i'm saying like i always i feel like
i always like wanted to
be like blue collar like i was maybe
like cosplaying or something
yeah because i remember not really
expecting my dad
because he wasn't blue collar what was
the rest of his family like or what was
like your aunts and uncles were they all
white collar blue collar what was it
yeah so my grandparents owned a
restaurant
in jersey that's what it is yeah so then
yeah so like
um but then my mom my mom's parents were
like factory work
yeah so there's my family there's a very
like blue collar mentality even though
we're like
you appreciate the art of a of a hard
day of work
yeah yeah it's definitely i think that's
how you make a i think that's how you
make
a trump supporter because you just you
don't realize that you have it kind of
good
and you act you think you're aggrieved
yeah you know you think you have it
worse
well that's what like i i've quarantined
in wildwood new jersey and it's all
[ __ ] trump supported like cut up car
like cutouts of them like
life-size flags everywhere so i think
it's because it's all
it's all construction workers from
philadelphia who were able to like they
weren't born into much
yeah or were able to like get enough
money yeah to start like a handyman
thing and then we're able to buy a
and you feel like being a vacation home
so they're like i was able to [ __ ] it's
like this
and you feel like because you did that
you're so smart because you learn how to
drill holes into a wall
you're like a [ __ ] genius shout out
to local 690 you know what i mean
yeah yeah so i was always impressed
those guys are pretty cool
no i was impressed too i remember like
my mom would always be very impressed
but
but like i always thought the guys that
came to our house to do work
were like cool yeah they were the guys
yeah i like kind of had i like respected
them
i got that i i've always gotten that
from you yeah so how'd you how did you
go from there to
ripping off housewives for because he's
like white he doesn't get his hands
dirty but he wants to be in the industry
you know what i mean
yeah dude i was the same way my whole
family was construction worker like
everybody it's all local
you know they're all steam fitters
[ __ ] plumbers carpenters
and i felt the same way when i got the
white collar like i was in the marketing
department
yeah this construction company yeah and
i remember like a sense of pride like
well at least i work for construction
i'm not you know what i mean
i'm not working at like [ __ ]
strawbridges or pennies or something
like that you know what i mean like
i do like sales though like i really
have a respect for for people who can
sell
and i think that like i don't know i
mean um
now that i'm doing you know since the
pandemic i've been doing some more like
moving so i'm doing like freelance
moving stuff so i'm setting up so people
contact me when they're moving
and then it's like a lot of that is like
sales you know
to make sure they pick you and not
somebody else you got to like
you got to wine and dine them a little
bit you wine and diamond but you make
that you you want to make them feel like
they're spending your money
like them spending their money on you is
worth it like
like they're happy to give you money you
want to make them go like oh i want to
pay you and not somebody else
yeah you want yeah exactly you want them
to have an emotional connection to you
to be like oh at least he's getting it
yeah i have i want to give it to
somebody i'd rather give it to that
give it to him yeah does that give you a
little peek into uh humanity when you
see people how they are when they're
moving and stuff like that
about how they act that's got to be the
that's such a tough job in new york i
imagine if you got stiffed on a tip you
wouldn't be happy about it
um no but i don't that doesn't really
happen to me
i'm good dude i just
i love the confidence i'm good you
[ __ ]
uh i haven't felt this confident cause
i've been spending so much time around
my wife
she keeps you unconfident well yeah but
usually i like build the tip into the
job as soon as i do okay
you give yourself a little cushion in
case you do get it but like to some
people act like jerk offs and stuff like
that to yourself not
really not really because you're like
you're helping them out right it's not
like if you're a [ __ ] grocery store
cashier that they don't respect
but dude moving to new york is like this
underworld of these rules that i didn't
i've never i just got a move
like last month or two months ago and i
hit up our buddy ravello peter ravello
because i'm like
i don't like they start hitting you with
how many of this you got how many stay
and like all these
questions and i'm like i don't know this
[ __ ] world so he walked me through it
like how much to tip
how many hours it's going to take he's
like what they're going to do is they're
going to quote you hey
you know it's this for two hours is it
going to take them six hours and they're
gonna hit you over the head with it you
know
oh okay there's a lot of like there's a
lot of that little
thing in the movie there's some yeah so
that's why i feel like that's why when i
quote a job i
he's a dirty dirty people you know they
are no hidden
no hidden seas were seen come on down to
mike's movie
yeah yeah what would be what would be an
expected gratuity for
for for to move a two-bedroom i mean
usually it's like 20
of the job split between the crew so it
would have to
it would just depend on what you know
what i mean
like what what i'm moving and how big
the
thing is but lately i've been doing
gratuity included
which i think people like a prefix i
like it yeah and then they don't have to
think party is six
yeah when i when i move friends and
stuff that's what i do i'm just like
retreating
yeah this is boring no
for a second it wasn't but then we got
there yeah um
uh new york city movie i know well this
i got my own truck that's the thing
yeah yeah yeah you got to get the
quilted blankets
those things are nice yeah yeah you show
up with those this guy knows what he's
doing
dude they showed up it was like three
[ __ ] eastern european guys and one
chinese guy who spoke like nine
different languages
four guys four guys all different
languages
and the one chinese guy spoke every
language and they were just putting
[ __ ]
couches on each other's heads and
walking down the [ __ ] four-story
walk-up
they emptied my apartment in like 14
minutes i hit that i give you credit man
i can't i hate
stairs i hate moving still worse i hate
it too but
you know it's good when you're done and
you get yeah you get paid
get a handful of cash yeah that's nice
yeah yeah that wouldn't cut still
he's got a miserable you just pace
yourself it's like drug dealer money
you're like i can make it all back
tomorrow when you
when you're making cash like that weekly
it's like oh this doesn't really exist
it's coming again tomorrow
you have to earn a check every two weeks
that [ __ ] stinks yeah i remember the
first time my first job at the
construction camp i got paid every two
weeks i was like yo what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm used to the cashier job
where you got paid every friday
yeah yeah i worked at got junk for a
little bit and that was like the only
corporate job i've had in the city but i
think that was like every week or every
two weeks
and sometimes they would like they would
like short your check and mess up
and you know because there were guys
that would write down their hours and
everything in their profit sharing
yeah you know and he's like and then
they take like
30 percent out for taxes yeah you know
i like what i'm paying now is zero no i
have to
i'm gonna file that i'm gonna fight who
the [ __ ] is the irs what's this [ __ ]
[ __ ] well no but it's funny because
when you get paid in like cash and venmo
sure
okay do i claim i'm obviously going to
claim the event well
you know but i just want to find a nice
i need a little
i need this nice scumbag account are you
asking us no i don't
yeah i don't know we're gonna have the
same problems now that we have money
rolling in
yeah i don't know what i'm gonna do
kevin ryan enterprises is about to
[ __ ] take a big loss have you guys
ever tried to cash have you ever
gotten paid by a check and asked them if
they could give you cash or try to cash
the check there
like have them cash it for you if they
want to pay with a check you should let
them pay with the check
i know but in my confirmation email it
says cash
i go no i meant any job you guys have
you guys what like your boss hands you a
check and you say can you cash this yeah
i don't even know if they can do that
legally they're not a bank i've been in
that type of situation
i've cashed mine a bunch at the
supermarket the supermarket will cash
payroll yeah it's like a check cashing
place
my mom used to pay for groceries with a
check i mean everybody did it so he
still did it
so embarrassed sort of why you [ __ ]
why is that embarrassing does it bounce
every time
yeah yeah yeah can you hold this for a
couple of days
okay so you know i gotta move some
things when he looks at the checkpoint
he's like oh that's the thing that makes
the cops show up at the grocery store
i'll start moving the carts i guess yeah
yeah yeah
yeah all right let's play a little
[ __ ] are you garbage let's get into
it let's talk about mike racine the man
as he is now we have a little bit of a
picture painted
um let's see if he's garbage i think you
came from probably pretty good stock
and now you're probably more garbage
than you were growing up i think
um yeah maybe i don't know we'll get
into it let's go into the house now
the more the more i the the more i think
about my family the more i go oh
some of you are like scumbags you just
have the venue
like the veneer of respectability
but i think outlook he has on some of
the members of his family that's crazy i
think my father might be like an actual
scumbag
because because he'll tell him what kind
of cars he drives that's what matters
he drives the honda accord old school or
so it's like
uh like a 2010 honda accord bunch of
papers and [ __ ] all thrown in there
no it's pretty clean but my my parents
are pretty good at like saving and stuff
like they're
bit they're big into so i think that's i
think that kind of makes it work because
like you don't even experience any joy
you're just
you're just the mentality of
accumulating money yeah not spending
really enjoying not even really enjoying
it
damn all right my dad doesn't have any
hobbies or anything
somebody's saying that he's gotta really
have any hobbies either what the [ __ ]
a hobby i have some hobbies you have a
hobby
you cook a lot you cook a lot is that a
hobby or you're just cooking
that's a hobby that's a hobby i guess
yeah if you like i'm gonna do this
i get really into food and stuff made a
pie for thanksgiving
you know what do you do what are you
doing
[ __ ] chips in a bottle what's going
on hobbies we don't even hear any
hobbies
i like documentaries yeah movies are a
it's a hobby
no but yeah i mean i'm not out there
like [ __ ] playing soccer or anything
yeah running pickup games no collecting
stamps
[ __ ] trying to get this thing off the
ground all right let's go into the house
now
all right you are married mm-hmm uh you
married recently married right last
couple years two months ago
two months ago the last couple of years
yeah [ __ ] i didn't know
congratulations congratulations thanks
open bar
well it's pandemic yeah of course
where'd you get married though
so we had like a little 20-person
wedding nice in bushwick
okay where we live rented a townhouse
had uh
a friend my friend nick whitmer who's a
comedy yeah yeah yeah he catered the
wedding he's a great cook it looks like
he's
seen things about nick whitmer's [ __ ]
cooking looks pretty fantastic
i know i i i'm a little like uh i get a
little
uh what's the word like jealous a little
jealous this guy's good
yeah that guy's good um if you need to
hire somebody to kate or something
oh great you should hire keep it in like
keep it in the comedy fan keep it in the
comedy face okay
dude he knocked it out of the park um
so yeah a little 20-person wedding her
sister officiated
we had parents and siblings and friends
and that was a couple friends
i did something very similar it's
awesome and then people send money and
nobody gets offended about not being
invited
he i didn't invite him to mine he got
very upset yeah and now i'm pissed about
years to be honest
nick whitmer behind behind [ __ ] ones
and twos well he was there to work
you could have catered it you've been
hanging out at the bus station you guys
want chips on these sandwiches
what do people call you they call you
just h i don't know henry
anderson foley yeah whatever what do you
call me
i try not to yeah uh yeah it's it's
interesting that you're you know you're
just an initial
yeah just a okay i'm just saying it's
nobody else does it am i on trial here
it's like you're an author or something
you're an author from the 1800s
yeah yeah yeah secretly racist
like you know writing under a pen name
yeah you write a bunch of monster
stories that's actually about jews
all right brush your teeth in the shower
sometimes yeah why does that make you
garbage
people would say i do it really it's
true
is it it's what they say yeah why is it
trashy
germs germs it's just disgusting all
right well do you keep the toothbrush in
there
yeah i have a little caddy yeah that
closes
yeah no not like a travel yeah that's
gross because like your wife's in there
showering and there's washing off dirt
and sweat
into the you know when you're [ __ ]
then because you're putting that into
your mouth this is what they say
9 out of 10 dentists agree with me by
the way i think the grossest thing is
when people use the you know the travel
toothpaste or the travel
toothbrush thing when they have that
just around all the time
that always builds up toothpaste you
need your t-shirt your toothbrush and a
covered
thing but see the thing is i don't see
what i'm saying they're gross
because they're always undercapped
they're never kept nice they're always
disgusting sure i don't really get sick
that often though
so i feel like it's good to have little
you know some germs there's some germs
in you
yeah i'll tell you this i had mice in my
apartment for a little while
and uh what floor what floor do you live
on first kept them for a year all right
yeah yeah yeah they like uh got me they
made my breakfast in the morning
yeah what'd you teach them yeah but uh
every once in a while like i'll
i'll turn a corner or something or i'll
open a closet
and that and now i'm moving so i'm you
know my
uh whole house yeah and uh i'll just
find
you know a pile of my [ __ ] mouse
droppings yeah
so then so then it's like you have to
clean it up they need to disinfect the
area
that they they were [ __ ] in it's
tough first floor in new york is like
you're gonna
[ __ ] have my you're gonna have them
in new york they're gonna cut the thing
that is they're gonna
they're gonna walk by it's just if they
stop or not what about roaches you're a
roaches
i think everybody in new york yeah
everybody yeah okay
but do you have them on me
my other my old apartment we did we had
a couple running around yeah
let's see keep the light on it's just
like it so you turn that light on they
start running away
yeah scary well you gotta get i don't
know figure something out
but i caught a few and i caught two on
the glue trap and two in a snap
trap yeah just the nice blue trap yeah
when they're on the glute chap they're
alive
uh-huh so i don't know what to do you
have to kill them
humanely yeah i think you drowned them
right that's what they think
yeah you put them in a bucket and it's
funny because that is not humanely you
smoosh them one shot
smoosh them with one but apparently
that's you fold you fold it over and
then you smoosh them real quick
i've done that before and apparently
that's like
i don't know it makes it's it's not
humane yeah i think that i did i think
the web's like
drowning how was drowning the most
humane thing
you're torturing them for a couple of
minutes minutes now i mean how big do
you think they're alone
when you drown them because that's what
i did i drowned them yeah where's this
guy
mike stop yes if you brush your teeth
well it's funny because you take the
trap
let me demonstrate you take the trap and
they're they're stuck on the glute and
they're moving around yeah they're
screaming
right dunk it in the water and the trap
is like going like this
in the bucket of water and then it just
stops moving
it's a [ __ ] death rattle now i guess
that's more now apparently that's more
humane than just
no because blunt force trauma is like
bad it hurts i don't know
you're like caving their skull in with
your boot they have to not feel it
it happens so you would think but i
don't think so you're waterboarding them
a little bit
i am pull them back up who sent you
yeah of course
she's like the mastermind yes michael i
don't trust them
but it's funny because then when you
pull them out they're dead but their
body is soaked
it's like soaking wet so it's like it's
like similar to you know the world's
worst
kid drowns yeah i enjoy not fun for the
kids
they're wet they're not just you know
yeah a little disturbing but then i
would imagine but i think you just got
to get used to it
you can never get used to well you gotta
get
you gotta
coming in hot that's uh patreon.com the
sit down everybody
i like it did you say it was a condo too
yeah like two floors
uh well no we're like renting a condo
from a family
from an italian family i got you yeah
all right leaving it there
yeah yeah all right bananas
but now i'm dealing with like a condo
board and stuff which is weird because i
i don't know if we're the only renters
in the building but everybody
you know it's like did you have to go
through the process of whether they
found whether they
they had to prove us you had to play are
you garbage with them a little bit yeah
yeah
mike shows up in his [ __ ] court suit
hello i own a transport company
i'm an importing and exporting uh people
belonging from their apartment no i
definitely don't just throw garbage into
a u-haul and take it to the dump
the mice i've never even had one yeah
gratuity is not included of course
um do you have a that brings me uh do
you have a suit that fits you now
yes you have like if you had to go
married just got married before that
before that did you or no
yes but it was a uh hand-me-down from a
friend of mine
a friend yeah because why didn't he why
is there sentimental value first of all
let's start let's start here
what who's the designer of the student
is it a real suit my suit
currently yes j crew suit that's what
was handed down
no the it was like a designer suit it
was like a lawyer
okay yeah and uh oh this is a different
suit not to jay crews
well he got the super before that right
because he got from a friend
because i was like i don't i only wore a
suit like twice a year so how did it
come off before you like hey do you have
any suits i could have
i said you want to sell me one of your
suits oh someone you're right
you're buying used clothes off your book
of your rich and then and then i showed
up at his house
and he you know he's like he's got a lot
of cash on him all right show me the
good stuff
you got any mice yeah
yeah yeah yeah did you really walk into
his closet and start perusing
would you mind killing of we have some
pigeons in the attic if you wouldn't
mind murdering them
we got a squirrel in the wall do you
have your hammer on you yeah
that is that is the fundamental if like
if i ever wrote like a crime movie
moving about crime it would be because
that's kind of the relationship between
like the ownership
and the and the and labor labor does all
the dirty work
sure so it would be from the perspective
of the guy who
does the dirty work sure who's like you
know not the boss
yeah like lefty you'd be like lefty and
yeah i guess yeah
the reason i asked about what kind of
designer suit is if it's it is like a
designer
it's really special yeah but that is i
can't see that's something you can give
it a friend
but i showed up did you pay for it or
did he give it no he gave it to me
but i said i didn't say i mean i don't
know what's worse are you guys the exact
same size
we're pretty much almost the same did
you have to get a tailor at all
uh no i don't think so wow he doesn't
seem like the tailored kind of guy if
he's like
if he's [ __ ] getting a hand-me-down
suit i don't think he cares how [ __ ]
how the pant drops
but to get my foot in the door i said
you want to sell me one is there a scene
you want to sell me
back to selling the windows yeah yeah
yeah hey listen
you don't i don't have to buy it soon
i'm gonna come over and take a look at a
suit yeah
are the decision makers of the home here
guys that's so
[ __ ] funny yeah can i get i need both
owners to be here
so you got all right so we just ended up
giving what were you what were you prepa
i can't even what were you prepared to
pay for a suit off of your buddy
hundred bucks get a suit for a hundred
bucks
but it's like an h m suit yeah but if
you were if you're only wearing it once
a year but i had a feeling that he was
gonna be like no just take it cause he's
like a guy who you know owns a lot of
suits
you know so i went to his house yeah
he's not a degenerate yeah he's at the
generator so i went to his house
he's probably like some scumbag
corporate lawyers sure but
or what pretenses did you show up at the
house at just to hang out
no i texted him i said i have a wedding
and go i go you have any old
suits you want to sell me oh there you
go because i knew he had like nice stuff
you're okay with that yeah
no specific purpose it's not like he
he's in his 30s the man's got a mustache
if you need a suit if you haven't he's
not 12. but if his buddy has an idea
if it's a knife the mall has nice suits
joseph a bank has
two cabins versace or something that was
actually i thought it was designed
but he doesn't he clearly doesn't care
about the suit i remember the first suit
that i ever got was from joseph
banks it was for my tenth grade purple
it was purple yeah
it was burgundy really the steve harvey
collection no it was it was like just
like a black suit that i needed and my
dad took
to joseph a banks to get a suit and i
remember like snl
did a sketch a couple years ago where
they were like it was like a mom
and she was like when my my family makes
a big mess and when i need to clean it
up
i use a suit from joseph and i remember
being like so offended
[ __ ] you hey listen lady that's not what
you make fun of okay yeah
yeah joseph a bank is shitty suits i
disagree i think they make a quality
product yeah but if you only wear a suit
like it's
fun to wear a cheap suit yeah sure you
know
or like you're a lounge singer yeah fly
me to the moon
uh yeah i mean that's why that's wildly
insane i mean i can see if you were like
really poor
but like a suit at eight why would i pay
for something i wear it like twice a
year though
because you're an adult no but then you
get the same that's true then you have
to get a shirt
get it from his buddy what's the matter
with you that's true he gave me a whole
set he gave me ties yeah like you're a
toddler that's what you that's what you
do to like that's what you do to like
your little cousin
you know like yeah i don't it's not that
i don't have the money to buy it i can't
justify i can't justify i understand you
don't have the money
the fact that you're going to get i have
a nice couch i sit on it every day
did he give you shoes too uh-huh yeah of
course
oh my gosh for tipping people in the
pocket
a little bit of walking around no i see
i i can't articulate it but what i'm
saying is
other than going under their false
pretenses if you just ask to borrow the
suit that's a different thing
especially if it's a real nice suit if
your buddy makes good i offered to give
it back to him he said no take it oh my
god i don't know how this is
how much did you resell it for uh yeah
it's on facebook marketplace yeah yeah i
get addicted i get addicted to selling
my friends clothing
that's crazy but i think he was like
happy i think he was like happy to give
it to me yeah
he probably makes too much money anyway
yeah he's doing well you're boys you
know
i'm just saying literally i go to like
two weddings a year i wear a suit
totally twice a year
a suit a suit will cost you a hundred
and eighteen bucks a brand new suit
from h m well for me i mean a lot of
like a shitty one
yeah but if it's shitty you're only
wearing it twice a year it doesn't
matter what's it okay let's start here
what's a nice suit to you
the micro scene right right now you can
go get a suit where are you going to go
well i know i mean it would be like a
designer suit but like
a j crew suit is like a perfectly
acceptable sure
how much was it how much was that that
was probably like 600
for everything but with shoes and
everything like that
pretty good 600 is a lot i'm paying
those 600
i'm not saying i don't have 600 dollars
i'm saying guys i do all right better
things to spend my money on
of course yeah how much were you gonna
give the friend you didn't say i did
he said a hundred percent i was giving
him like a hundred bucks yeah
but he was like no don't i'm not i don't
i never wear it and we're the
exactly the same size i'm giving i'm
giving you this i think what
i you wear your dad's suit that's why
yeah cause i love them now they're
already all worn in too
plus it keeps candy in the pockets i had
to do that once
i'm in fl i'm not currently in the
market for a suit i'll tell you that
right now
and when i my first job in the city i
was the doorman at caroline's and i had
to wear a suit
every night for that and i bought this
suit from men's warehouse that like
didn't fit me it was too big
oh man there's like this giant suit with
big baggy pants yeah
i don't know why confirmation so it's
like
it's such a crapshoot buying a suit you
don't know if it fits you right
so you just like you know i don't want
that to happen again
i had this like big boxy gray suit i
know i
used to work at macy's i have to i used
to have to wear a suit every day it was
the same thing i had more like my dad's
hand it was like a double breasted
yeah i had like the [ __ ] big
shoulders yeah yeah yeah i look like a
[ __ ] idiot look at a salesman from
microsoft
just but the idea of like you could even
go to the uh to a thrift store and get a
night and get a decent suit sure and
then you take a picture in it like
you're an immigrant
you know like you're an immigrant from
the 1930s
like a proud and you make no money but
you're just a proud
trying to have your dignity got one of
those old suitcases
you know yeah leaning on a barrel
because you have two fans cause you have
two families
you're like a dust bowl farmer
oh man all right um have you ever worn
pants that zip into shorts
uh probably but not in a while okay
but i do like yeah i don't know no
i don't yeah yeah i mean okay that's a
no it's fine
oh i know what you're talking about like
the cargo the but yeah they like zip
into shorts
i don't think i ever have okay yeah okay
you rock jean shorts
yeah still yeah i will
or when jeans get old when jeans get old
i make them into shorts
that's old school name that's for that
that's that's like
that's like 1980s italian right there
that's [ __ ] old-school guido [ __ ]
do you have your own car um not anymore
was the last time you had it uh like two
months ago i got rid of it
okay yeah did you wash your car yourself
uh
no okay like i said i i had a
i thought that about you mm-hmm you look
like you wash your own car i don't have
like a hose in space yeah do it in the
city you got like the bucket and [ __ ]
that's a mess i didn't think that's true
jeffrey's like she's only doing it on
like [ __ ] seventh avenue you're like
where do you live
you're watching your car just pictures
him out there in like gene shorts with
the radio on
deborah
start a sauce okay how much cash do you
have on you right now
probably like 46 i would say
okay pretty good that's something that's
in the wheelhouse yeah but sometimes
up to like 300. coming off a job
yeah or just in your pocket yeah uh it
sounds in my pocket well that'll be like
if you're leaving you'll take from the
house
300 bucks yeah yeah is it 20s or is it
hundos
what are we talking here mike um both
yeah just kidding
i like to keep the cash in my drawer and
that way if my wife needs cash
she can just go to my drawer that's a
real man thing and i feel that with my
wife and i have no money she has
[ __ ] way more money than go to the
drawers but i'll be like should is there
any cash in the house i'm like there's
50 here like whatever i'm like yeah
there's cash i love
being able to say it's typically and
it's also nice to hide cash all over the
house
oh yeah yeah that's garbage yeah
i love it it is fun though but you don't
want to deposit
it because you don't want you know if
you get paid in cash you don't want to
deposit it
i saw this episode of judge judy one
time that made me so pissed
this guy was like this guy was like yeah
because the guy had a conflict with
with like a family friend because the
family friend co-signed on a truck and
he was the guy was like
yeah i'm a tattoo artist and i do other
freelance stuff so i mostly get paid in
cash so i don't have credit
and judge judy was like oh she's like so
you don't have to lie to me she's like
you you say you're a cash guy so you're
not a tax guy
and it's like yeah i bet you pay every
[ __ ] dollar you owe you yeah
yeah yeah you scumbag she probably has a
lawyer who
charges like seven hundred bucks an hour
yeah
yeah that's dirt pulling so many levels
you yelling at the
if you go out to dinner you're paying
cash you like when you go out no because
i could double the points on my jet blue
credit card
so at a restaurant or grocery i try to
use the credit card
i get double the points so i can fly to
[ __ ] fort lauderdale
or west palm beach for a nice little
vacation
i have like a hundred thousand jet blue
points where can you go with that
i don't know but it would have to be
like allocated in a divorce i think my
jet blue points
where can you go well jetblue is weird
because they fly domestically and like
to the caribbean but they don't fly they
don't fly anywhere
yeah like internet like international do
you think that if you got if you got
divorced tomorrow do you honestly think
that the jet blue points
would be would come up for him
hold on it's under you it's your card i
would probably just use them yeah it's
my card
i just buy a bunch of tickets what is
spiteful
you don't even know if she's coming
after you you don't even get to go to
san juan that bro yeah yeah
i'm going to albuquerque three times
what's up yeah yeah yeah that's funny
that's trash
yeah yeah i'm going to charleston south
carolina you [ __ ] [ __ ]
they got a hug
i'm just going to sit in the airport and
have a sandwich yeah then i'm coming
right yeah yeah yeah i'm going to
charlotte
oh my god
i don't know why i picked jetblue for my
credit card but i did i tracked
i did fly them a lot but i would like to
use up the points and get a different
airline
but you get two times the points at uh
restaurants and grocery stores
dude i've hit my i've hit my credit
limit as far as like how far i can go
it's only 200 bucks we know it's 500 but
i don't think i can get a card that has
like something where i earn points
because
i got an offer from capital one for like
some silver streak or something
yeah that does earn points and then i
filled it out just like i filled out the
other one yeah and when i filled out the
other one just automatically went
through
this one's all of a sudden like oh you
gotta send us a w-2
and [ __ ] they want to know you know
this and that and the other thing so i
just kind of
walked away from it yeah they wanted
some proof of some things yeah
which in this economy i wasn't readily
to discuss with somebody i didn't know
yeah of course
that's pretty good speaking of money do
you currently owe anybody money
no pretty good pretty good you clean on
the street
my wife does yeah i'm clean on the
street my wife owes student loans though
that's fair
you take those on she locked down the
block
she's in for a nickel with sharks i feel
pretty good that i don't have student
loans that's right i dropped out of
college
so you know yeah just like when people
talk about their student loans i'm like
you know yeah you're more honest i have
like 38 000
that's patreon.com are you garbage
everybody that's not too bad i guess
it's yeah it's 30 average it's all right
yeah it's below it's probably below the
national average
how much was that dump to go to school
there every year well
see the issue is uh they approve you for
a bunch of money
uh and yeah i use that money to [ __ ]
party and stuff like that
yeah and you would get it in checks once
at the beginning of the semester so they
would send the money
to i went to temple so they would send
the money to temple
and then temple would cut me a refund
check of everything on top of that when
you're not staying in the dorms you
don't pay them for the dorms
so like at the beginning of every
semester i get a check for like [ __ ]
you know
12 grand or something what yes that's
[ __ ]
awesome we only got a little bit of that
yeah well i'm now [ __ ] 34 years old
still paying it off
my fraternity house was like 1500
difference in the dorm so i would get
that refund at the end of the semester
i thought i was big time starting off
fifteen hundred well that was the post
that was supposed to be ran and then
like my mom would be like will you give
me that money
so you don't spend it and then i'll like
give it to you to pay rent yeah and then
like
i'd give her half and be like oh there's
nothing with the bank they don't let you
send it all like that type [ __ ] hey
toots i got a better idea
yeah right the draft horse has dollar
beers on wednesdays
i see yeah drive this off into the
sunset yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
when you had your car
did you ever buy used tires oh sure yeah
of course you're yeah beaded seats this
guy you're a real
this is like you got a lot of real
dirtbag tendencies yeah yeah you go to
the junkyard
no but they the place that i would take
the car to would have used tires
okay yeah yeah yeah i used to go out of
pep boys i assume
uh no but i do
i got the tires and then somebody like i
bought the tires somebody and somebody
else was looking at the tires and they
was
they were like i know you said i know
you said these tires are used but
these are like used
you still got them no i got rid of the
car
oh my god but just having a car in new
york city doesn't make any sense to put
money into it because
stuff happens to it i have like a two i
have a 2005 mercury montego
it's been hit by like a city bus it's
all you the bumpers are all [ __ ] up
for and it's like
yeah there's no point imagine he makes
fun of me and he's like dude your car
sucks i'm like well
it's a [ __ ] new york city car it gets
[ __ ] smashed up it's on the street
yeah
there's a lot of empty water bottles in
the back of it it's stunk before it got
into new york city i'll pay that
oh sorry my mommy didn't buy me a car
but it's funny because you feel like
you need to have a nice car why because
i mean you're probably your wife wants a
nicer car
i know she makes fun of my car but she
doesn't care does your wife want a car
she wants to like get rid of her car and
get in and get
like either like lease a new car to go
elise
car yeah but why would you want to drive
a new car in new york
in the
every car i've had gets like [ __ ] up
yeah like the bumpers get hit
yeah like are like i got sideswiped and
then you just like they [ __ ] keep it
moving
yeah it happens especially it's like my
deductible i got shitty and short and so
it's like i'm not going
[ __ ] sitting there doing paperwork
and like following a clean get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah
fair enough fair enough you ever have
any family that lived with you
um just my grandmother for a little bit
when she got into a car accident
okay so uh i when i was in like 10th
grade i
asked my grandmother to take me to
blockbuster so i could rent billy
madison
i was like and then it was raining and
she got she like ran a stop sign
wait were you in the car with her yeah
and billy madison in 10th grade
yeah how old are you i'm your age yeah
so that was i mean like you ever had
probably seen it by like yeah
yeah but i wanted to watch it again yeah
yeah okay i was gonna say
that's a long [ __ ] i mean it came out
in the mid 90s yeah and then my dad
showed up to the accident he was like i
don't know why you guys had to leave the
house
yeah did they blame you um a little bit
but then the cop was like
sir let me give you some advice like
save it for home it's not now's not the
time and my dad was like yeah you're
right you're right
you're [ __ ] they just love authority
how bad was your grandmother hurt
and she like broke her leg and like hit
her i guess what about you
i was okay i was in the back seat was it
on the way home or on the way on the way
home yeah
did you watch the movie when you got
home i mean i think i did yes
i don't remember it probably not that
nice i gotta take my mind off
i gotta clear my head a little bit
comedy stylings of mr adam sandler yeah
really she had to move in with you um
yeah she lived with us for like a couple
weeks i guess
oh your dad must have been pissed is it
his mom it was his mom yeah no i think
he was happy
oh it was nice having her there yeah
makes sense well there you go um
have you ever that's like a very like um
i don't know
there's cultures that do that they it's
nice having your family live with you i
love it
you know your older parents i wouldn't
want
my parents in a nursing home with me i
wouldn't mind my biggest fear
what put my parents in a nursing home
yeah because my grandmother had to be in
one because she had uh alzheimer's yeah
we used to have to go every sunday to
see her yeah and i [ __ ] i just knew i
didn't want her there i hated it yeah
used to cry and [ __ ] yeah cafeteria was
pretty tight though i'm not gonna lie
yeah i don't think i would even mind
like my in-laws living with me i don't
know it's fun my cousins grew up with
their
my two cousins had their um their aunt
and their grandmother lived with them
yes awesome yeah just around christmas
yeah because they [ __ ] hooked it up
yeah yeah yeah it's tight what about you
baldi yeah no
gift cards i would put my parents in a
home for sure would you
yeah i don't care they got cash it'd be
a nice home
you know what i mean what am i i'm not a
[ __ ] you know
assisted living what are they going to
move into my one bedroom apartment in
washington heights
help me move the car to the hospital
hospital get a two bedroom and get in
here
now you get up you have them live in the
podcast studio
bobby quiet yeah machines are going off
and you just have to send her out yeah
hour a week
send her out go hang out at two brothers
for a while yeah yeah yeah yeah somebody
got
somebody got murdered there three nights
ago really yeah they apparently they
were friends so
you should feel safe um have you ever
owned a sopranos poster or t-shirt
no never waited in line to meet a
celebrity
no you a wrestling fan yeah okay
have you ever applied to work at
enterprise rent-a-car no
why is that why is that the thing what
what
enterprise rental car yeah because it's
a real scumbag job like the door-to-door
salesman yeah
they take anybody yeah no they're always
at like every
uh college fair you know what i mean you
sign up and it's like you know this they
teach it it's like oh this great sales
manager yeah it's like it's uh
it's definitely a scam okay not a scam
but it's you know
jericho i thought enterprises like the
classier rental place they pick you up i
hear
yeah come on not bad more of a hurts guy
the juice well nobody will rent me a car
my credit sucks
wait is that a thing that or i don't
have credit cards or something i don't
know
i can never run a car so i always gotta
give him like [ __ ] 500 cash for two
weeks
yeah i'm like buddy it's a neon just
give me the [ __ ] key i have an
account
at uh cc rental in new york city uh-huh
so i have an account there
so you can if you need to rent a car
i'll do it i'll
wait those cc rental trucks they also
rent cars too yeah i thought they were
strictly for the movie business
um no really the best best uh truck
rental in new york city
everywhere yeah and they're open 24
hours flat rate
you know so now do you get the weight
he's selling it to us like he's got
[ __ ] you know you got something we
got to sign right now i need both
drivers to be home
you just use my account and then you
bring your license and then you should
be good to go you get jet blue points on
something yeah that's the
if i can get 100 jet blue points every
podcast i do
i'm actually coming out on top of pocket
that's my
funny dude yeah um do you currently own
any n1 basketball shorts no
well actually i just got rid of them i
just got rid of a pair they didn't make
them
in the garbage no yeah yeah it feels
good to throw clothes in the garbage
so fantastic yeah cathartic yeah
um if you were to go swimming do you
have a bathing suit or would you wear
uh basketball shorts i have a bathing
suit it's glass board shorts or
elastic band elisa band okay where'd you
get it
um
yeah that's awesome um all right i have
uh
two from uh from our patreon listeners
uh guys when you sign up for patreon
we'll ask one of your questions
we would love to ask them from everybody
but we just get too many uh
too many submissions so when you join
the patreon we'll ask one of your
questions
um this is from austin alexander have
you ever bought furniture from a
second-hand store
um i don't think a second-hand store but
definitely
you know used furniture on the screen
yeah take anything off the street
i'm sure yeah a few processor ones ever
have bedbugs i've had it for a long time
um not in my room but in my apartment i
lived in an apartment
on the first floor and the front the
front room always
got a bunch of bed bugs but i never got
them that's tough i don't know is that
true
what's there yeah they just never made
it to my room
they saw the mice yeah um
i was a big as-is section at the which
is trashy the big as-is section at ikea
uh-huh dude my [ __ ] wife found out
about that thing and that's all
we [ __ ] we got like our whole first
apartment from the as-is section oh
really
yeah it's like a you know we get a
stained couch and like a bang dub washer
machine that's like
it's like return [ __ ] or [ __ ] they got
broken on the floor or whatever but
worked out save a couple of bucks you
know what i mean i just don't see the
point in buying
furniture that's it's weird because you
buy nice furniture it's just for you
it's not like people notice anything we
just got a [ __ ] new couch delivered
last night
uh or yesterday morning and that's nice
but it's a brand new one it was it's a
white couch yeah what are we doing with
them
[ __ ] that up you got a dog no but we
want to get one
so it's just like it's yeah yeah so
we're like [ __ ]
yeah i got a micro suede couch which is
like easier to clean that those are yeah
yeah yeah you got a couple of dogs
still you got a couple animals very
classy it's a nice kitchen it's a nice
couch having a nice couch is
nice that's big it's big you spend a lot
of time on it yeah
all right hmm i think i only got one or
two more here yeah
um this is from tornatioed what
something or
tornadio yeah have you ever eaten canned
good straight from the can without
heating it up
um like as a meal or just to like try it
well yeah i eat cantuna a lot because
when i'm like working out you and you
want to get that i think that's okay
that's like functional that's not like
we're talking like baked beans yeah did
you ever just open a can of corn or
something and just start going at it
riding the rails kind of thing
if i use chickpeas in a dish or
something i eat a few chickpeas yeah but
that's as you're yeah
you washed you guys you guys washed them
out i i really washed them out
people you're supposed to keep that
juice in there that juice bugs me out i
wash your mouth yeah
the juice is too bad too no i don't like
the juice yeah cause there's weird
bubbles that come when you
put water in the can yeah it's weird
yeah do you wash chicken before you cook
chicken
you're not supposed to i think you are
supposed to i don't think you're
supposed to
well i do rinse it because sometimes you
there's if it smells
yeah you got it you rinse it off and
then it still smells good
nick whitmer actually told me this if it
still smells after you rinse it off then
you shouldn't use it
wow yeah but a lot of meat in new york
city that you buy
smells a lot of chicken is a lot of
smelly chicken in new york city for some
reason
yeah god knows i thought i was buying we
went to uh
shop for thanksgiving just seeing all
the turkeys everywhere and stuff like
that
[ __ ] gross yeah i used to work at a
butcher shop
yikes they play it fast and loose with
those [ __ ] expiration dates i'll tell
you that much
yeah all right before we get out of here
i do want to ask
uh let's talk about tomato sauce okay
yeah
all right growing up what was the
situation
well for the listener mike makes his own
sure kind of famous
not famous but you know if you're known
to make a proper song
i assume this was understood with this i
guess but i don't do it as much anymore
because it's just like it's a
pretty big hassle i tried to make it
last or two christmases ago
and uh i don't know it's just a lot you
have an opinion about this subject
though
sure so let's you're a learned man when
it comes to sauce
sure i guess i know more than the
average person are you 100 italian
i'm 5 8 italian five yeah who the [ __ ]
says that's
like five eighths my dad is all italian
and my mom's a quarter italian
what's she she's irish italian and
polish
so you're italian mostly italian growing
up was there sauce being made or was
there jars
yeah we would do like sunday dinner at
my grandmother's house so yeah but she
would make it and jar it
so but we didn't buy jarred sauce okay
but
she would make her own sausage and jar
yeah so you
there was no prego or regular not really
never francesco
ronaldi no and i always i was always
kind of a snob about
right you go to somebody else's house of
course yeah i would go to somebody
else's house and they would serve like
prego or ragu and i
you could just you could just taste the
the difference you know
how about a glass of wine over here huh
yeah that's funny
um and then if have i i mean when was
the last time you bought jarred tomato
sauce
i'll buy like a good jar like what's a
good job
would you say that's the one of the only
ones you would buy
maybe yeah because it was it's weird
like
the the sauce the bran clasico is pretty
popular
i i uh looked at a list of like the best
jarred tomato sauces on the internet
classico is number one for some reason i
don't think it's it's
it's not but they must i think they pr
probably lobby pretty heavily yeah they
probably paid for the [ __ ] research
i think big sauce money you know because
i was shocked that they were
but the probably the best sauce you can
get at the grocery store is the the rayo
sauce and it goes on sale every once in
a while yeah
it's not bad yeah starting to get a
little cheaper too it's starting to get
more popular it's like 10.99 or
something in my place
okay yeah which isn't too bad yeah you
got to be careful with some of those
like artisan brands though cause some of
them are not that good
i don't want to name any names but name
them what do you got you just trash
francisco
well classico yeah that's big people
that's big money
well there's a brand called uh michaels
of brooklyn that i was never that
impressed with
okay it's a little bland you think
there's a little like jealousy you know
the whole michael's the whole
we don't see that i mean if there was
like a you know
kevin of another kevin ryan a comedy of
washington he also doesn't like dogs
so i've been told i'm gonna say
i mean i thought you were class i still
think you're classy i think he's pretty
trashy do you think so
yeah i mean the su i can't get over the
suit
the walking around with 300 cash on him
is a little shady i think i think he
operates like a gentleman i respect
just nice to pay cash yeah not have to
worry about your identity getting stolen
that's a little that's a garbage thing
he's worried about his identity being
stolen
that's a guy who thinks everybody's out
to get him do you listen to alex jones
no not ever since he went commercial
uh i'm saying i'm saying 60 40 60 trash
that's my number he's classy comes from
good stock yeah
i don't know the the fact that he's like
holds so much value in his points too is
pretty
that's you know it's not the classiest
thing around but
i get it i was a big i had a delta
credit card for a long time never
i want to start a chromebook but nobody
nobody looked at my suit was like oh
that's a hand-me-down suit
you know sure um but nobody would have
looked at an h m suit and been like
that's a trashy suit either
he might have no he got a better suit
though i got a better
a better quality suit yeah he went
shopping in his buddy's [ __ ]
closet that's trash that's what you do
as a child this this is the point i'm
making if it was an h m suit that the
guy handed down to him then that would
be garbage but
it's a nice respectable designer suit
it's a little bit different
yeah and maybe a little but it's okay if
you get your dinner from a dumpster is
that
you know is that bad what is what huh if
you go to a if you go to a dumpster
let's say you find a mcdonald's you know
number one listen it hasn't been touched
in a dumpster yeah yeah it's still it's
still a mcdonald's uh sure but if i was
a meal if i was hungry and i called my
buddy and was like hey man are you
making dinner and he's like yeah we're
making dinner right now like
i'm gonna come over to have something to
eat he'd be like yeah sure okay that's
not what i did though or i could have
just stopped on the way over and bought
mcdonald's
more but as an adult on my own but if
you call your friend you say hey you
want to sell me some of your dinner
and then you go over and he eats the and
you eat the food and he goes nah don't
you pull out your wallet come on let me
let me pay for this
i get the point we pay for this eggplant
i love mike racine everybody mike is
there anything you want the folks out
there to know that you got coming up
just my podcast the sit down it's uh
wherever you get your podcast and uh
follow me on instagram
racine.mike and i'm mike racine on
twitter
yes sir kippy what do you got to folks
out there need to know uh as always
a couple of points of business make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes
we're in the top 200 a review will
really help us i know a lot of people
watch on youtube uh if you do watch on
youtube go drop an itunes review
uh it helps it out with the stat with
you know with the stats
also uh subscribe on youtube if you
don't already
patreon.com are you garbage you can
[ __ ] sign up there you can help
support the show help us
pay for the studio keep the [ __ ]
lights on you get a lot of bonus content
podcastmerch.com get yourself a t-shirt
uh other than that guys i'm
kevin i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media
and of course let's tip our hat to our
old pal
toby mcmullen t-bone we love you kid
we'll see you guys next week peace